today's topic this uh came from one of
the lives we did can you hear me
yeah yeah we can hear you all right so
you want to turn your camera on
uh unfortunately i can't turn the camera
on it's all [ __ ] up right now sorry
max
it's all good it's all good i know how
it is cell phone cameras don't work
nowadays
so what's your uh what's your what's
your struggle
well i wouldn't necessarily say it would
be a struggle i just kind of
want to like give you all i got the
limit that i had
so about two and a half years ago i was
gonna get married to basically
high school sweetheart kind of like and
um
you know we had basically gone through
all middle school and all high school
together and then when we graduated of
course we kind of broke apart
i made some mistakes and she made some
mistakes and then we got back together
and that's when i had moved from
louisiana all the way up to
montana and that's when she actually
made the effort to come up to montana to
see me and that's when we were like okay
you know [ __ ] this we're gonna get
married we both had made that decision
we bought so wait wait stop stop stop
stop stop see y'all we're seeing for
each other for a bit then y'all moved to
different spots
she came to visit you and you wanted to
get married because she came to visit
well what it was when we had split over
when we had split away for the longest
time you know we had been together for
like like six years going to school
together so when we had broken part i
had moved
and then she had didn't come up to see
me because she was traveling with her
family because she knew
she was trying to plan on joining the
military so she wanted to travel around
before she
actually got you know strung up doing
that [ __ ]
so when she came to see me and before
she had left um
and you know we basically made a plan to
have basically get married together and
you know
okay all right all right all right so
you got you guys got married for that
reason all right
all right
i'm talking i'm gonna say this as kindly
as possible right and anybody who's a
service member will probably
don't sit don't go in if you are young
okay and you are seeing a girl you know
you guys are in a relationship it's
going well
she's going to go to basic training
she's going to be away from you
okay she's basically single okay
there's no kind way to put this all
right but have you got a girl y'all in a
relationship but she go to basic
training
she's basically single that's how it
would be the amount of things that i've
seen
in terms of like listen we um we didn't
have a large platoon 60 people
four girls wrestling with dudes all
those girls either came up and like they
were relationships or married or
whatever
by the time they were done basic
training those those two three months
bruh
some people had trains ran on them some
people
just did they dirt and never told their
husbands i've seen so much
okay and most guys will tell you man do
not date a service member driving
someone else who's in the military it's
a terrible idea but if you're a civilian
you're not even in the area she's locked
in a way in a building
doing all these rigorous drills with
people who are also in decent shape
hopefully not all
some they're gonna get booted right bruh
she'll be lonely people there for
attention it's going to be stressful
some guy slides in but like hey
hey if you don't need to clean your
rifle i can help you tonight
maybe you can polish my rifle later all
right corny [ __ ] like that happy
trains happen too true true true she
going to basic bruh
you making a mistake if you're trying to
marry this girl she's trying to marry
you before she goes to basic
this is why i tell you bro why don't
y'all just stop seeing each other let
her go to basic let her go do her dirt
after she's done
see if y'all want to revisit it then and
then ask her you know how many [ __ ] did
she gobble during that period that's
none of your business
if you're about to get back with her
it's not your business okay
it's not a business hey the reason why i
say you should ask just to understand
what it is that she's dealing with when
she's out there anyway she's gonna lie
yeah it's none of your business if
you're willing to take her back take her
back
don't ask don't ask about the past don't
do it
don't do it do not do it she goes on
deployment and you back home
nick and everyone's gonna say something
listen i don't care i've seen so much
on military bases people living in pmqs
i don't know what it is with military
couples a lot of them are freaky freaky
like weird ways like very aggressively
so i don't know what the studies are i
have no data to back design i'm just
telling you what i've seen well people
have told me
hey bro do not do it okay there's a
reason why i didn't touch a single
military girl during my time in the army
i would never
it's not a good idea and i'm in there
i'm i'm going to the same mess hall
you a civilian bro this is my suspicion
you know i just think this is such
suspicion
go ahead she's going to an extreme
change in her life and she sees you as a
stable point
so it's monkey branching okay
and you know what the song says i don't
want to be a monkey branch
so that's what it comes down to do not
do it man oh it's just a terrible idea
what do you think
you said what you said yeah i got
nothing else to add that's going to be
it's going to add value value to this
video
you said what you said i died for a
reason i i died when he saw me oh yeah i
know yeah i'll let you win it
i i'll let you go in all right i'm not
gonna judge your reason that's her
choice
so what's the issue so we we didn't end
up getting married she had gone to basic
training and after she had gotten out of
basic training she basically you know
flat out told me that she wanted to be
on her own and she wanted nothing to do
with me
okay see you died after she got done she
wanted to be on her own
okay i actually didn't remember what
happened in this clip so this is perfect
yeah
this is literally what i expected to
happen yeah you lucked out
if you would admit oh bro you lucked out
because she got ran through
she got rid of hey i heard you really
dodged one
yo let's go
all right all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
stop this right here i'm gonna i'm gonna
stop this
right here let me let me
all right yo man you know what it's like
it's when you know some and a [ __ ]
don't know
and he's just waiting like this you
about to red pill them
um
why why why why what is it yeah
and you're about to be like okay let me
go in that's right that's right
you know what it makes me think of it
makes me think of like those times when
like someone comes he's like hey man i
bought this new watch oh man what's
that's a rolex where'd you get it
awesome doing the trench coat at the
[ __ ]
how much you paid for it i paid like
half price five thousand instead of ten
sit down sit down we need to have a
conversation
that's it that's exactly what it i
promise you if you think i'm making this
up
anybody who's done the army you guys can
leave comments tell me i'm lying
this is your time now the comments your
time your comments go ahead there's a
lot of stuff that i ended up learning
firsthand
i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna just say this
as kindly as i can
if y'all are under 30 and she going to
basic sing
training uh she about to be basically
single feel me
basic training where a woman is
surrounded by 60 men
who are all topped up on exercise and
sweating
and y'all in the trenches and you got a
boyfriend at home who you may not see in
a long time
your relationship is over it is done so
leave leave okay if you are a man and
your girl trying to join the military
give up oh man yeah i mean flashbacks
right now oh yeah
flashbacks bro flashbacks 30 30. i don't
know what's wrong with the army why it
attracts so many degenerates and weirdos
but yo it does
and those couples on military bases bro
dude's going off to [ __ ]
deployments fighting iraq wife is doing
gang while he's gone
crazy stuff it goes down not in the dms
in a pmq okay so that's pretty much all
my thoughts on that uh
dating somebody who's from the military
it's a very arduous lifestyle so unless
you're really
down for that commitment if you think
the divorce rates are high for regular
citizens
it gets crazier for the military because
you guys are always isolated you have to
lean on each other because you're
constantly moving around
so it makes it puts extra strain on the
relationship even with the kids
i talked to people who were raised on
military bases about to move around
because their parents
they got a different lifestyle that's
why they had the term military kid
yep because they signed a contract it's
a different
different game it's a different ballgame
so just the information for you guys
yeah
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below would you guys marry
somebody who's joining the military
and if so what was your experience
[Music]
me